it's been a year now since the verdict
and today you're launching project
include to speed up diversity and
inclusion in tech why do you think this
will work when so many other things
haven't we've pulled together a team of
women who have almost 150 years of
collective experience in tech so we've
seen all the problems we've seen all the
issues and we have a set of
recommendations of what people will be
able to do to solve these problems and
we think that our years of experience
the research that we've done will really
make a difference now if you give this
information in these recommendations to
CEOs startups companies what makes you
think they'll actually listen we've
actually had a couple who have said they
want to use our recommendations and
they're willing to participate in our
startup program and we also shared it
with a bunch of CEOs and engineering
managers and other types of executives
and they've they they say they agree
with what we recommend it so we're not
telling them to you know fire everybody
and start from scratch these are just
ideas that have come through actual
experience things that people have
actually done things that we know and
are sure will work so it's coming out of
you know people's experience the
research that's out there it's just
pulled together into one integrated
document or website that will help
people do what they say they want to do
in a way that we think will actually
show which companies have actually
committed oh we can't talk about that so
we're we're still talking to people and
but I'm excited that people are
interested and that people agree with
what we're saying now tell me how it's
gonna work cuz you're gonna work with
VCS who do have a lot of influence over
these companies you're working with
companies of a certain size you know who
will do this in-house so we have two
different programs one is for startups
and then the one for VCS is still too
early to talk about the one for startups
were looking for 18 startups that will
are that are between 25 to 1,000
employees and size and we want to have
three meetings with them basically one
to get things started you know what kind
of recommendations are you going to do
where are you in terms of your metrics
today what metrics are we going to
collect over the six months a second one
to three months in to see like where are
we how are you doing what's working
what's not working let's all learn
together
and then a third meeting to figure out
like where did we end up what really
worked what do we want to change in our
recommendations based on these
experiences and you know what's next so
for companies as big as Google Facebook
Apple where we're talking thousands tens
of thousands of employees yet women make
up 30% of the workforce 20 percent or
less in technical roles is it too late
for them I don't know we're focused on
the size of companies where we think we
can really make an impact where the CEOs
can really move things where you know
this idea of innovating and changing
really quickly and moving on the fly is
most most appropriate and most impactful
so what will your role personally in
this initiative be are you committing to
this full-time no we're all it's been
funny like we pulled this together this
project out of just our spare time
working together really enjoying our
process of working together and getting
a lot of things done so this has been
kind of a passion project for us on the
side and we're all going to continue in
our own work but continue to drive
things forward as a team